en novembre les saveurs d'automne
prennent place dans les assiettes de ce
restaurant de gaz rend cet établissement
participe à la semaine gastronomie
d'automne de rambouillet territoire
myriam bourgeois la directrice et le
chef sébastien bourgeois sont les
parrains de cette 24e édition et cette
année encore ils font découvrir leurs
recettes automnale on propose donc les
pâtés en croûte de chevreuil aux cèpes
aux trompettes de la mort au pied de
mouton ça dépend là pour les fêtes on
passera sur la truffe ont fait évoluer
on aura également le lièvre à la royale
ça c'est un simple afa également de la
maison qu'on fait depuis depuis toujours
donc un lièvre qui entièrement désossé
qui est qui est farcie la force est
réalisée avec du foie gras de la truffe
d'eric vos desserts si les feuilles
deviennent oranges en ce moment cette
chocolaterie porte cette couleur toute
l'année situé à rambouillet cette
boutique gourmande va proposer des
dégustations et des animations
découvertes autour du chocolat on
commence à parler des marrons glacés des
pâtisseries à base de marrons justement
ce côté un petit peu automne et on vous
propose également des animations qui se
font en fait sur le point de vente mais
l étage pour expliquer en fait d'où
vient le chocolat la torréfaction des
fèves de cacao pour faire notre chocolat
la découverte automnale de la
gastronomie du rambolitains se poursuit
aux essarts-le-roi cette biscuiterie
participa gastronomie d'automne depuis
2007 pour faire découvrir ses délices
nous allons leur proposer une
dégustation des 15 recettes
pendant cette semaine là avec le rocher
amandes enrobées de chocolat comme comme
une truffe ou alors des notes de notre
caramel caramel beurre salé le rocher au
caramel beurre salé ou le florentin au
caramel beurre salé organisé par
rambouillet territoire gastronomie
d'automne se conclura le dimanche 28
novembre avec le marché de la
gastronomie et de l'artisanat à
rambouillet